Prof: Today we're going
to talk about these phylogenetic
trees that we've been discussing
for the last couple of sessions;
and this completes the three
introductory lectures on methods
that are used,
or basic concepts that are used
in macroevolution.
So we began that with
speciation, so that you can
understand where the branches on
the Tree of Life came from.
And then we had a quick
overview of how to construct a
phylogenetic tree,
so that you could see how the
whole tree was put together.
And now we're going to see what
happens when you either lay
these trees onto maps,
or you put traits onto the
trees, or you do both at the
same time.
This is basically comparative
biology, in its modern sense.
The outline is first a bit
about looking into time;
using phylogenetic trees and
looking into geographic history.
Then we'll look at how we can
map traits onto trees and draw
some surprising conclusions.
And then we will put trees
together with traits and put
them on maps and see what that
tells us actually about
evolutionary ecology of lizards
on Caribbean islands.
And then we'll end with a
take-home message from
comparative biology,
which is that species are not
independent samples,
and that because they're not
we need special methods for
trying to assess how frequently
things evolve in the Tree of
Life.
And that will lead us into both
looking at how seeds do in sun
and shade,
in related species,
and the issue of whether you
should be more faithful to your
mate if you're going to be
married to her for a long time.
Okay, well let's start with
some of Godfrey Hewitt's work.
And this has to do with what
happened in Europe after the
glaciers melted.
Now just to remind you about
what Europe looked like at the
peak of the last Ice Age.
The glacier came down out of
Scandinavia and got down about
into Northern Germany and
Poland.
The English Channel was dry
because there was so much water
that had been locked up in the
continental ice sheath that the
level of the earth's oceans
dropped about 100 meters,
and at that point there was a
sub-glacial tundra that
stretched essentially from
Ireland all the way across
France and through Russia,
out into Siberia.
So there was pretty much--it
was called the Mammoth Step.
And at that point many of the
animals that you now find in
Northern Europe had retreated
south, into glacial refugia.
There was one in Spain,
there was one in Italy,
there was one in Greece and the
Balkans, and in Asia Minor.
And you can now take the
mitochondrial DNA out of these
various organisms that are
plotted here,
and you can reconstruct where
they spent the last Ice Age,
and how they got back into
Northern Europe.
So, for example,
most of the grasshoppers of
Northern Europe came out of the
Balkans,
and the ones that spent that
time in Spain never got over the
Pyrenees.
The hedgehogs managed to get
over the Pyrenees and spread
through France and Belgium and
the Netherlands.
However, about at that point
they met the hedgehogs that were
moving north from Italy,
and there were a bunch of other
hedgehogs that were coming up
from the Balkans.
The bears, interestingly,
managed to do just fine,
getting out over the Pyrenees,
and they moved right up into
Scandinavia.
And up in Northern Sweden they
have met some bears probably
that had been in the Ukraine and
had come out from north of the
Black Sea;
and so forth.
So it's possible,
using mitochondrial DNA,
molecular phylogenies,
to reconstruct the recent
history of movements of animals
across the planet,
and trees, across the planet,
and to understand why it is
that there are certain places
where we see hybrid zones.
And in fact here are some
hybrid zones,
in Europe.
These are places where you will
frequently run into hybrids,
and they are there because
populations are coming back
together that had been isolated
in the Ice Ages and breeding
with each other.
So, for example,
this is one I know pretty well,
because I went there for
thirteen years.
There's a spot in the Swiss
Alps, in the eastern part of the
Swiss Alps,
just north of the Italian
border, or just south of the
Austrian border,
right about here,
where almost every flowering
plant that you see is a hybrid.
And the guidebooks are just
lousy, they just are horrible.
It's extremely difficult to
identify what you're looking at.
But when you see the big
picture, you can understand it.
So if you're interested in this
kind of thing,
this is a good paper to read,
by Godfrey Hewitt,
and the papers that have cited,
that have cited that one;
those are good sources.
Now what about humans?
Well I'm going to show you
first what's happened in about
the last 10,000 years,
and we're going to see that in
Europe the agriculturists spread
out from the Middle East and
squeezed the Celts into the
northwest.
In Africa we're going to see
the Bantu migration out of
Cameroon, and how the Hottentots
were squeezed into the southwest
of Africa.
And in Asia we'll see that
agriculturists spread from both
the Middle East and from China,
and squeezed Siberians into the
north.
So these things are laid out in
a beautiful book by Cavalli
Sforza, Paolo Menozzi,
and another author,
Alberto Piazza,
I believe.
And basically what they did was
they tried to come up with a
method of compressing a huge
amount of genetic information
onto a map,
and they did it by taking gene
frequencies,
at hundreds of genes,
and then compressing them,
using statistical analysis,
into a few factors,
and then plotting those factors
onto the map.
So what you can see here is
basically the population
differentiation of humans,
in Europe, and you can see that
there is kind of a wave that
comes out of the Fertile
Crescent and moves up to the
north and to the west.
And this tracks the
agricultural expansion,
which started about five or six
thousand years ago,
out of the Middle East.
And you can see that the Celtic
genes did get squeezed up into
Ireland and England,
and out into Brittany,
and so forth.
So there are lots of neat
details in this book.
If you focus in on particular
areas,
you can see that there's a
hotspot,
right in Palermo,
of Viking genes from the Viking
occupation of Sicily,
etcetera.
Interesting stuff.
If you look at Africa,
what you can see is that there
has been an invasion of Africa
by Caucasoid Northern Africans,
and by sort of an Arab Nilotic
expansion,
coming down this way.
The Bantu expansion out of
Cameroon is what is coloring
part of the continent pretty
red.
And, by the way,
this migration got through here
about a thousand years ago.
So the Bantu migration down
into East Africa is something
that is relatively recent.
And if you've been reading
about the war in the Congo,
and the conflicts between the
Hutus and the Tutsis,
the Hutus are Bantu,
and the Tutsis are Nilotic,
and you can see where the
Nilotic and the Bantu mix comes
together here in the Great Lakes
region of Central Africa.
So this kind of map gives you
some feel for the way things
have moved.
By the way, there was a kingdom
in Mali, centered around
Timbuktu--or an empire--and this
orange spot is a relic of that.
So the history of human
movement on the face of the
globe is written in the genes
and can, to a certain extent,
still be recovered.
This kind of study will no
longer be possible after another
few hundred years of jet travel
and crossbreeding.
My son, for example,
is in a relationship with a
woman from here.
Another few generations of that
and this map will not be
reconstructable.
If we look at Asia,
what we see is that there were
nomads and agriculturists coming
out of the area around the
Middle East,
and around the Black Sea and
the Caspian Sea,
that have pushed into Central
Asia,
and the Chinese
agriculturalists have spread
into Southern Asia.
But there's a very interesting
hotspot of human biodiversity in
southeastern Asia,
going from India over about to
Taiwan;
and actually this is where the
Polynesians came out of.
The Polynesians left from
Taiwan we think about 5000 years
ago, and that's confirmed both
in the language reconstruction
and in the mitochondrial DNA.
That just came out a few weeks
ago.
So you can see that one of the
themes of recent human history
has basically been of the
expansion of some groups at the
expense of others,
and that that was often a
technology-driven thing,
and often involved agriculture.
Now, I've shown you this
before, and I just want to bring
this back in again,
at this point,
to indicate what you can do
with phylogenetic trees,
and just to remind you.
It is now possible to get
information on single nucleotide
polymorphisms at 650,000
different sites in the human
genome,
and this is a paper that did
that for 928 unrelated
individuals from 51 populations.
So these are the 928
individuals out here.
These names down here are the
51 populations,
and the 650,000 different
positions in the human genome
are on the Y axis,
all compressed together;
so it's very hard to see any
differentiation there.
And you can see that there is
certainly a genetic signature
across this;
certain kinds of genomes in
certain geographical areas.
And if you then do the
molecular phylogenetics on it,
and construct the phylogenetic
tree,
you see that the oldest part of
the modern human tree is
centered in Africa.
This, by the way,
is the Classical view.
This was a picture that could
be drawn in 1995--and this is
2008;
so this thirteen years
later--and this tree largely
confirms this picture.
Okay?
So you could lay this tree onto
this map and come up with
something that looks pretty much
like this.
What you see here basically is
we came out of Africa,
we paused in the Middle East.
Then various groups moved out
of the Middle East.
One group went into Europe,
thought to be about 40,000
years ago;
that's these guys.
Other groups set out into Asia
and spread out through Asia.
And then out of the group that
had settled basically in Eastern
China and Japan and Korea,
one group up here split off.
Part of them--actually an early
part of this branch--
went down here,
through Papua,
New Guinea,
into Australia,
and another part went out into
the New World.
So phylogenetic methods can now
be used to give us quite a bit
of insight into our own history,
as well as into the history of
other plants and animals.
Now the Hawaiian Islands are an
interesting test case.
When we look at something like
the human expansion across the
globe,
it's actually difficult to get
precise markers for the times
when they arrived in certain
places.
Archeology gives us some;
sometimes we can recover fossil
DNA from bones.
But in the case of the Hawaiian
Islands, at least on the scale
of the last 5,000,000 years,
we have very precise geological
dates.
For example,
we know that Kohala Mountain,
the oldest rock on Kohala
Mountain is 430,000 years old,
and that the oldest rock on
Kauai is 5.1 million years old;
and that's because the islands
are made over a hotspot here,
and carried on a plate up in
that direction.
And you can actually lay down,
on this plate,
how long ago it was that that
island was actually sitting down
here.
And that's nice,
because when we then do
phylogenetics and we start
putting phylogenetic trees onto
this map,
it gives us some feel for when
in time those different branch
points might have been.
And that has been done for a
number of groups.
I'm sure there's now more
information.
This is about five years old
here.
And these are three different
ways that spiders and some other
arthropods and some insects
speciated over the last
5,000,000 years in Hawaii.
Interestingly,
you can see that they all moved
down from Kauai onto the younger
islands.
So they were going from older
islands onto younger islands,
and they just kept hopping.
And, by the way,
if you just continue this
island chain up to where it
dives into Siberia,
there were islands there
350,000,000 years ago that are
now getting subducted under
Kamchatka,
and there are things that are
one or two-thousand miles up to
the northwest that were once
high islands above water.
So this hopping movement could
have been going on for quite
awhile.
And, in fact,
we think that some of the
things that we now see in Hawaii
got there about 20 or 30,000,000
years ago, before Kauai came
above water.
So it's an old process.
At any rate,
in some cases things simply
moved from one island to the
other, and then every time they
got onto a new island they
speciated.
In other cases there were four
or five species from Kauai that
moved down to Oahu,
and then several of them sorted
out on Oahu and speciated on
Oahu,
and four or five of them moved
down to Maui Nui,
and so forth,
and then a lot of them
speciated on Maui Nui and moved
over to the Big Island;
and that process went on.
Another process is one where
you have a lot of species on
Kauai.
One of them moves to Oahu.
You get a lot on Oahu,
but only one then is the
ancestor that goes on to Maui
Nui,
and you get a lot there,
and then one goes onto the Big
Island,
and then you get a species
complex on each of the five
volcanoes on the Big Island,
that are coming from that one
ancestor.
So all of these processes can
actually be seen written in the
genes,
and this is all resulting
basically from sequencing,
either nuclear or mitochondrial
DNA.
There are other kinds of
questions that you can answer.
And this is one that was
answered by Anne Yoder,
who was on the faculty here.
She now is the head of the Duke
Primate Center.
And Anne has specialized in the
mammals that live on Madagascar.
And on Madagascar you find a
local radiation of things that
look kind of like civet cats or
mongooses.
And the question was,
did they come over from Africa
separately, or did they all
speciate on Madagascar?
And Anne was able to
reconstruct the phylogeny of
this group of animals well
enough so she could lay this
tree onto this map and determine
that in fact these guys are
actually all relatives of
mongooses,
and mongooses are close
relatives of hyenas,
and those things have a sister
group of civets,
group of cats.
And they got across right here.
Now Madagascar split off from
Africa about 65,000,000 years
ago.
It's part of the Tectonic
breakup that led to India
splitting off,
skitting across the Indian
Ocean, crashing into Asia,
and raising the Himalayas.
And so you might wonder,
well how the heck does
something like this cross a
strait which is now more than
200 miles wide?
Well have any of you read
Rudyard Kipling's story,
How the Elephant Got His
Trunk?
"Down by the grey-green,
greasy Limpopo River,
all set about with fever
trees"--
the elephant child looked into
the water,
and a crocodile grabbed his
nose and pulled it out,
and that was how the elephant
got his trunk.
Well the grey-green,
greasy Limpopo River is right
here.
And in flood stage,
if you go out on the Limpopo
River,
there are large rafts of trees
and vegetation being carried
down it,
and in a good storm you can put
a mongoose on a raft of
vegetation and get it out across
that strait;
so it rafted across,
and it probably came out of the
grey-green, greasy Limpopo
River.
Okay? So that's right here.
Now what about issues--I'm
running through a series of
issues that can be resolved
using comparative methods in
phylogentic trees.
And this represents one of the
phylogenetic surprises.
There are parasitoid wasps
which can be either
ectoparasites or endoparasites.
The ectoparasites lay their
eggs on the outsides of
caterpillars,
and the eggs hatch and make
little baby wasps that crawl
around the outside of the
caterpillar,
and they eat it from the
outside.
And they have relatives who are
endoparasites.
The Ichneumonids are like that.
Here's a nice Ichneumonid-like
wasp.
You can see her long ovipositor.
And here she is on an insect
larva, and she is injecting an
egg into it.
And the ancestors turn out to
have been wasps that did this.
It had been thought that if you
just look at it mechanically,
it would be easier to start the
evolutionary process off with
the wasp just flying around and
laying its egg.
Right?
But in this particular
radiation--that may have been
the case far in the past;
somewhere off the slide out
here there may have been an
ectoparasitic wasp that was an
ancestor.
But it turns out that all of
these things are endoparasites,
and the ectoparasites evolved
within that,
and then within the
ectoparasites you had a reversal
again and got some endoparasites
out of it.
So if you lay the traits onto
the tree, and you are confident
of your tree,
you can reconstruct the history
of an important trait like this;
and that's a nice kind of
insight to be able to have.
Okay, now I would like to
discuss the Anolis lizards.
And this is something that a
large group of scientists,
currently centered at Harvard
but with branches in Seattle and
in St.
Louis and other places,
have been working on for about
the last fifty years.
And they study Anolis lizards
because these are prominent,
easily observed;
you can get a pretty good
sample size fairly quickly.
And they've done fascinating
things.
So the Anolis lizards have had
a big radiation on islands in
the Caribbean,
and they have made what are
called ecomorphs.
Now these ecomorphs can be
grouped by appearance.
So if you look at them and you
see where they're living and
what kinds of grasping
appendages they have,
basically what the phenotype
looks like and how they behave,
you can come up with things
that live on the crowns of
trees;
out on twigs;
down in the ground in grass and
in bushes;
between the trunk and the crown;
only on the trunk;
or down on the ground and going
up on the trunk.
Okay?
So there are six ecomorphs.
And you find them again and
again.
You find them on many islands
in the Caribbean.
And it's really tragic that in
the middle of winter,
up here in New England,
you have to be continually
flying down to the Caribbean to
increase your sample size,
okay?
And doing that for twenty or
thirty years,
through many generations of
graduate students.
Well, after DNA sequencing came
along, you could do their
phylogeny.
And look just--it's hard to see
because the reproduction isn't
very good on the slides--but
just look at the difference in
the color pattern.
Okay?
So, for example,
this is the trunk crown's
space.
Well, it turns out to pop up
here, and here,
and here, and here:
one, two, three,
four times, independently.
Or you could take something
like the twig form.
Here's a twig form,
here's a twig form,
and here's a bunch of twig
forms.
Now what's going on here
basically is you're having the
independent evolution and the
convergence on different islands
of these different ecomorphs,
among these lizards.
And if you take that down and
you break it down by island,
what you can see is that on
Cuba the trunk form,
the crown trunk form was
ancestral.
On Hispaniola,
the twig crown form--or no,
this is trunk crown and this is
crown giant;
this is a crown giant form,
was the ancestral form.
So these are inferences about
what first got onto that island
and what first got out to the
other island.
And then these other things all
evolved from that.
And what you see from that
basically is that it doesn't
matter which form of lizard you
first throw onto an island;
all of the other ones are going
to evolve from it.
And these are all different
species.
And we're talking about things
that range in size from about
that big, up to about that big,
and that are differentiated at
the level of genera.
So this is really major
evolution,
which is being repeated again
and again,
across the Caribbean,
and generating essentially--
what's going on here is that
essentially the same ecological
community is being generated
again and again,
independent of which kind of
species founded that group.
Okay?
That was highly unexpected;
people didn't think this would
happen.
So this means that you're
getting the same ecomorphs from
different ancestral states,
and that means you've got
convergence.
Okay, now for an insight from a
guy named Joe Felsenstein.
And if you want to go back to
the original paper,
it's in 1985.
So this is one of Joe's many
contributions to phylogenetics.
If you just look at this
picture that I showed you the
other day, you can see that the
red trait evolved in the
ancestor of both B and C.
Okay?
So that means that B and C
share a trait.
However, in evolutionary terms,
it only evolved once.
Now at this point,
the reason that red increased
in frequency might have been
that it was adaptive.
Things that had the red state
had a fitness advantage.
So microevolution was driving
it at that point.
But then everybody inherited
it, and it is not an adaptation
to the difference between
whatever environments B and C
now live in.
So if you were to look at B and
C now,
and you saw that they shared
some trait,
you wouldn't really know why
that was there,
until you could get a much,
much larger sample size;
because you just have a sample
size of one, when you're looking
at that trait.
Okay?
So how do you deal with that
problem?
Well Joe came up with what he
called the method of independent
contrast.
And in this context a contrast
is the difference of the value,
the mean value of a trait in
one species and its value in
another species.
And if you look up just at the
tips of this phylogenetic tree
and you take the differences
across the closest related
sister pairs,
at the tops of the tree,
you generate these contrasts.
You get X2 minus X1;
X4 minus X3;
and so forth.
Well the important thing about
the contrasts is this.
The difference that evolved,
after this point on the tree,
is independent of the
difference that evolved after
this point on the tree.
You've taken out whatever was
there because of the common
ancestor.
So whatever was going on over
in this part of the tree is
biologically separated and now
statistically separated by this
method,
from whatever was going on in
any other part of the tree.
So this actually is a method of
getting the correct sample size,
off a phylogenetic tree.
And that's very important in
statistics, because if you have
the wrong sample size,
all your statistical tests will
be wrong.
So this was important for the
mental health of people who were
doing statistics on phylogenetic
trees.
So let's take a look at some
approaches that are kind of like
that.
So this is from a guy named
Peter Grubb.
Peter was the president of the
Ecological Society in the UK.
He's a botanist at Cambridge.
And what he's done here is plot
the log of seed mass of
light-demanding seeds,
against the log of seed mass of
shade- tolerant seeds.
And his question was this:
Do plants living in shade
produce larger seeds than plants
living in sun?
And he wanted to do a
phylogenetically controlled
comparison.
So what he's doing here is he's
taking essentially the value
within a genus,
or within a family--the mean
value of species within a genus
or the mean value of genera
within families--
for related trees,
some of which live in open
areas and demand light for their
germination,
and others of which have seeds
that can germinate and survive
in the shade.
So the open circles are
comparing genera within
families, and the closed circles
are comparing species within
genera.
And what you see here basically
is this.
Plants living in shade do
produce larger seeds than plants
living in sun,
but you only see it in
comparison of genera within
families;
you don't see it in comparison
of species within genera.
Okay?
So the ones that need light and
the ones that need shade have
just about exactly the same seed
size, if you are looking at
species within genera.
But if you then give them
longer to evolve,
you go further out on the
phylogenetic tree,
you compare things between
families,
where that contrast is
possible, then you start to see
them moving off the one-to-one
line,
and the ones that are
shade-tolerant have seeds which
are falling quite a bit-- not
all;
this is an exception--but quite
a bit above the line.
So this is a way not only to
answer that kind of question,
using the comparative method,
but also to get an estimate on
how long it takes.
It takes a long time to
generate that difference,
because you only see it at a
higher level on the tree.
Now what about the albatrosses
and their relatives?
These are the
Procellariiformes,
the Tubenoses.
You can see the Tubenose right
here--and that's a Wandering
Albatross;
and you can see the Tubenose
right here on this Petrel.
And these things have totally
different life histories.
Okay?
The Wandering Albatross,
which has a wingspread of
between twelve and thirteen
feet,
and is probably the heaviest
flying bird,
it lives on islands in the
Southern Ocean.
And it mates,
usually starting at about the
age of twelve or fifteen or so,
and it usually will produce an
offspring every other year or
so,
for about thirty or forty years.
They mate for life;
they're monogamous.
And they have very precise
homing behavior to their chicks.
They lay their eggs on places
like South Georgia,
Macquarie Island,
places in the Southern Ocean.
And some French biologists put
a radio collar on one of these
Wandering Albatrosses and
tracked the mother as she took
off to go get lunch,
for baby.
And she flew north,
from South Georgia,
and she peeled off towards
Australia and flew up the West
Coast of Australia,
and came back across the Indian
Ocean and down the East Coast of
Africa,
and back down to South Georgia
a month later;
at which point baby,
by that point,
was extremely hungry,
got a lunch of rotten squid.
And this wide foraging means
that they're only going to be
raising one child every two
years or so;
and there are all kinds of
adaptations in the infant's
physiology to deal with this
irregular feeding.
A Storm-Petrel is a lot smaller.
It forages much closer to shore.
It is not so faithful to its
mate.
These things are related.
Okay?
So if you look within this
family, can you ask the question
about whether or not a long life
really is a situation that
promotes mate fidelity?
The argument there is basically
that if you're going to have a
short life,
there isn't going to be enough
time to pick up the advantages
that you would get from knowing
a particular mate,
and adapting behavior to that
particular mate,
and learning exactly how to be
a good parent with that
particular mate,
rather than with some other.
And if you look across the
Procellariiformes;
so this would be the Wandering
Albatross up here,
and this would be a Petrel down
here,
and you've got some other
things in the middle--
these are all separate species
now;
the dots here are all species.
And we have here a study in
which--you are looking at
independent contrasts now,
and we're plotting the
independent contrasts.
So this is the deviation in
adult life expectancy from an
overall mean,
for the whole group,
and this is the deviation in
mate fidelity from an overall
mean.
So the ones that tend to live a
long time are more faithful to
their mates,
and the ones that tend to live,
have a short life,
are much less faithful to their
mates and switch mates.
And that's interesting because
in fact these guys,
the ones that reproduce many
times, have much more
opportunity.
They have thirty or forty years
of reproduction.
They could go out and they
could get divorced and pair
again several times.
But they don't,
they stick together.
And the functional reasons for
that are things that are not
really terribly well understood.
Student:  What's
negative mate fidelity?
Prof: What?
Student:  Negative mate
fidelity.
Prof: Negative mate
fidelity is just a statistical
thing.
They are taking the
overall--they've measured mate
fidelity on some scale,
they've taken an average for
the whole group,
and then they are asking,
how far does this species
deviate from the average?
So if it's below average,
it gets a negative number,
and if it's above average it
gets a positive number.
Okay?
Okay, so now I want to ask you
a question that comes right out
of molecular phylogenetics,
and I want to see whether or
not you can actually put
together some information that
you've now gotten from different
lectures.
So this is going to require you
to piece together phylogenetics
and genetic drift.
So this is the figure from the
Becky Cann/Allan Wilson paper
that came out now twenty years
ago.
It's basically on human
mitochondrial evolution.
And what it showed was that all
human mitochondria appear to be
derived from an ancestor,
all of whose closest relatives
now--
the close relatives now are all
out at the tip of the tree--
lived in Africa.
You don't start picking up
non-African members of this tree
until you get out to this point,
and then you can see that by
the time you get way out on the
tree,
that most of these now are
non-Africans.
So assertion number one out of
this is, hey,
human mitochondria show that we
came out of Africa.
Well we now know from that
paper I showed you more
recently,
from SNP polymorphisms,
that this is an extremely well
supported thing,
and that we see it in the
nuclear genes as well.
But the claim here was an
interesting one.
It said there was one woman,
living in Africa,
about 220,000 years ago,
from whom all other
mitochondria in all humans on
the planet are descended,
and so they gave her the name
Mitochondrial Eve;
that's observation number one.
Observation number two--and
this now comes from an
immunobiology group in Germany--
and basically it has to do with
how old are the polymorphisms in
our MHC genes?
And these are things that have
been selected,
probably through frequency
dependent selection,
in co-evolution with diseases.
And the observation is this.
Say we have two MHC genes that
have resulted from a gene
duplication--
and that would be this one here
and this one here--
and at each of those genes
there is a polymorphism,
so that we have different
alleles at that locus,
for each of those two genes.
Who are those alleles most
closely related to?
Well it turns out that Allele 1
in humans is most closely
related to Allele 1 in chimps,
and Allele 2 in humans is most
closely related to Allele 2 in
chimps.
In other words,
the closest relatives of the
alleles are not in this species;
they're in another species.
The only possible way that that
could have occurred is if the
polymorphism originated before
the speciation event--
okay?--so that you had
ancestral species here,
and this polymorphism
originated, and you got this one
coming down from the ancestral
species into the chimp,
and into the human;
and this one coming down from
the ancestral species into the
chimp and into the human.
Now, on the one hand we have
the claim all the mitochondria
came out of one person.
On the other hand we have
evidence that there are
trans-specific polymorphisms.
And if you take this point in
time and you put it on this
tree, it's about here.
I now want you to talk to each
other for a minute,
and then we'll see if you can
come up with the explanation for
how those two observations are
consistent with each other.
So just turn to your partner
and figure it out.
<<Students confer with
one another>>
Prof: Silence descends.
Enlightenment has been reached.
Okay, can anybody tell me why
they are not surprised that all
of the mitochondria came from
one female?
Why are you not surprised?
Student:  Because
they're going to come down
through meiosis.
It comes down
Prof: It's asexually
inherited.
How many females do you think
there were in the African
population 220,000 years ago?
Do you think the second
observation tells us anything
about that, the trans-specific
polymorphism?
What happens when a population
is really small?
You get genetic drift.
If a population were as small
as one female,
it would've been impossible to
maintain this trans-specific
polymorphism.
People have done simulations to
find out what is the average
size of a population that would,
over a period of 5,000,000
years, maintain the amount of
trans-specific polymorphism that
we see in our MHC complex;
in other words,
the amount of genes that we
share with chimpanzees,
where our alleles are more
closely related to the chimp's
alleles than they are to the
other human alleles?
And the answer is the minimum
size is about 10,000.
In other words,
we have good genetic
information that tells us that
the smallest the human
population ever has been,
over the last several
hundred-thousand years,
actually over the last
5,000,000 years,
since we shared ancestors with
chimps,
is about 10,000.
Okay?
Given that, now tell me,
are you surprised that we can
trace all the mitochondria,
in all the females on the
planet, back to one woman,
living in East Africa about
220,000 years ago?
And if you're not surprised,
I want to know why.
Yes?
Student:  Well you were
talking before about how
recessive genes spread out in a
small population.
So if she had enough children
over enough generations,
you'd have enough of a
population
>
Prof: Okay,
it's possible that in fact she
had a particularly advantageous
mitochondrion,
and that it then got selected
and it fixed,
and then everything would go
back to her.
That's correct.
And that could've been done in
a larger population.
However, it could also have
been done with drift,
and it happened so long ago
that we can't really tell
whether it was selection or
drift that gave that one woman
the advantage.
By the way, the same thing has
been done for the Y chromosome.
Okay, the Y chromosome is also
asexually inherited,
and the estimate on the Y
chromosome is roughly also about
200,000 years ago,
also in East Africa.
And the fact that the
mitochondrion and the Y
chromosome both converged to a
common ancestor,
at about the same age,
might suggest that drift is
more likely than selection to
explain it.
But basically what's going on,
if you think about it,
is that in any process like
that, if you go back far enough
in time,
it will always converge on a
single common ancestor.
Okay?
Now the next thing I'd like to
tell you is that there was a
controversy about when that
happened;
and the controversy on dating
that point of convergence is all
about how long has it been since
we split with chimps?
Because that turns out to be
the baseline that gives us an
estimate of how rapidly
evolution is going on,
molecular evolution is going
on, in the human clade.
Well when you apply that
criterion to what the confidence
limits on the estimate are,
hey, it was anywhere from last
year to about a million years
ago.
>
So the confidence limits are
lousy.
The observation,
however, that that person was
in Africa is pretty solid and,
as I say, is now confirmed by
the nuclear genes,
the SNPs that I showed you
earlier in the lecture.
So the point of this exercise
is that when you see results
like this,
when you see some claim of
Mitochondrial Eve,
or Y Chromosome Adam--which are
both out there in the
literature;
just go on Web of Science,
type Mitochondrial Eve,
you'll pick up a lot of
controversy about this.
I want you to realize that (a)
we should never be surprised if
particular mitochondria or
particular chromosomes converge
at some point in time--
it looks like they were just in
one individual.
That's just because of the way
that branching processes work,
and that will be going on all
the time, and it's happened over
and over and over again.
So it's no surprise that it
goes back to one person.
The other point that I would
like to bring out is that if you
contrast different kinds of
historical evidence,
you can often gain
enlightenment by seeing that
there is a puzzle that needs to
be solved.
And in this case the puzzle
basically is that this tells us
something about population size,
and this tells us very little
about population size.
This process,
convergence back to a single
ancestor from the mitochondria,
it's not entirely independent
of population size--
it'll take longer in a big
population than it would in a
small population--
but it doesn't give us an
estimate of how big the
population had to be.
Whereas the trans-specific
polymorphism could only have
been maintained,
even with strong selection,
in a population that was larger
than about 10,000 individuals;
and that can be done with
computer simulations.
So these are different forms of
enlightenment into the history
of genes in a particular clade;
a history that happens to
matter to us quite a bit.
And we can gain that by looking
carefully at phylogenetic trees.
These are actually both
phylogenetic trees.
This tree here is just laid on
its side, and you'll find that
this is commoner and commoner
practice these days.
If you look at the cover of
Nature,
or Science,
or the--actually the one I
remember is in the New York
Times Science Section for
Darwin's birthday,
on February 12^(th).
That week the Science Section
had a phylogenetic tree covering
Darwin's face,
and it had thousands of species
on it,
and they're laid out this way,
just so that you can fit the
species onto a piece of paper.
So time kind of wraps around,
in the way it's presented.
Okay, so to summarize this part
of our exploration of
macroevolution.
These molecular methods allow
us to reconstruct geographic
movements, as well as
phylogenies.
And we saw that in the
hedgehogs going north from Spain
and the Balkans,
and we saw it in the humans
moving out of Africa,
and we saw it in lots of things.
We see that our own migrations
have left genetic traces on all
the continents.
And there's an imprecise map
that's suggestive between the
genetic geography and the
linguistic geography.
Greek genes go with Greek
family names,
from the boot of Italy,
up to about Rome,
and then stop;
that kind of thing.
So even in the last two or
three-thousand years,
you can see that family names
and genes have been inherited in
similar ways.
We can use these methods to
determine which trait states
were ancestral and which are
derived.
And that was particularly
interesting in the case of the
parasitic wasp,
whether it was an ectoparasite
or an endoparasite,
because it changed received
opinion about fundamental
biology.
And this method that Joe
Felsenstein worked out for
independent contrast is
something that will control for
common ancestry,
and it can reveal the
correlated changes in two or
more traits that have taken
place since branches in the
tree.
So it can be used as a fairly
powerful method to explore
hypotheses in behavioral
ecology, evolutionary ecology,
and ethology.
So next time we're going to
start talking about key events
in the history of life;
it's the first of three ways to
look at the history of life.